been a statement from the German
government in the last few moments the
German government has said that training
of Ukrainian troops is to begin in
Germany soon Germany will also provide
Logistics ammunition and maintenance to
the Ukrainian armed forces the German
government says the goal is to quickly
establish two battalions with leopard
two tanks for Ukraine initially it will
provide a company of 14 Leopard 2 A6
tanks from its military stocks the
German government has also confirmed
that it is to approve the re-exports of
German 2 tanks from partner countries
obviously you'll recall that earlier in
the week the Polish government formally
applied to Germany for the right to
re-export its own leopard two tanks to
Ukraine obviously a Singh stand Germany
has to be able to approve the re-exports
of German manufactured tanks to Ukraine
we can go to our correspondent Siobhan
Robbins who's in Berlin Siobhan I mean
it looks like the German government has
caved in after an enormous amount of
pressure from its allies
yes we've been expecting this much
speculation coming in last night that
Germany was poised to announce not only
that it will be sending a company of its
own leopard two tanks that it would
finally allow allies to re-export their
own stocks and this as you say is after
immense pressure particularly from
Neighbors including Poland who's the
last couple of weeks have really been
ramping up their criticism of Germany
saying that if they didn't get official
permission to send their leopard two
tanks they might just make a coalition
and send them anyway now many people had
been speculating that this decision
could come last Friday when of course we
saw dozens of Defense ministers meet at
Ramstein it didn't and when we asked the
question why sources here have been
suggesting two things one the chancellor
is a particular character he doesn't
like to be pushed he likes to make
decisions in his own time and there was
a real feeling that there was a concern
about the fact that by sending leopard
two tanks there could be an escalation
in the war and also that if Germany did
this alone it potentially could be a
Target so we did of course see the UK
pledging to send 14 of its own
Challenger 2 battle tanks that didn't
seem to be enough though and there was a
feeling particularly last week that
conversations were going on behind the
scenes with U.S officials trying to get
a similar pledge from the U.S to send
some of their Abrams battle tanks now
the word we're getting out of the U.S is
that following an announcement today by
Germany that we're going to expect to
see a similar pledge by the us and this
is an important step because we know
that there are around 2
000 leopard two tanks around the world
many of them are in Europe the exact
numbers of how many can be pledged we
still don't know we know that Ukraine is
looking for around 300 and how many go
will depend on how big a difference they
will make but these modern tanks will
make a difference because as you've seen
in our reporting from Ukraine for
example from my colleague Alex Rossi
many of the ukrainians fighting are
using old Soviet tanks so the fact that
they can use these modern battle tanks
will make a difference there are still
things to be ironed out how quickly will
they go how many will go of course as I
was saying how long will the training
take and also how will the Kremlin now
react